thomas alors une journée marathon pour
le président qui rend des comptes aux
agriculteurs oui le président de la
république qui est interpellé à de
nombreuses reprises par les différents
agriculteurs les différentes personnes
qui le rencontre dans ce salon de
l'aviculture
on a notamment assisté à une scène ce
matin où le président de la république a
été interpellé par des jeunes
agriculteurs des jeunes agriculteurs
membres de la fnsea qui était
visiblement inquiet je propose d'écouter
cet échange
sachez que mon à l'école est à l'écouté
de la société
on n'est pas des apprentis sorciers on
n'est pas des gens qui peut y en a
partout par vent tourner il ya des mères
de famille des pères de famille on sait
ce qu'on fait et on respecte nos voisins
et la société par contre aujourd'hui
comment vous pouvez sortir des choses
comme ça son compte par de compensation
on va avoir des d hectares en moi il ya
des gens qui se posent des questions à
savoir comment ils vont vivre
on sait que le monde agricole passe des
moments difficiles
au niveau économique voilà on attend des
réponses à dessus autrement je suis
désolé va y avoir une cassure entre vous
et nous et j'en suis désolé
ce à quoi je tiens c'est sûr qu'on s'est
engagé tous ensemble c'est à dire la
baisse des pesticides
la sortie du glyphosate avec la formule
que sur lesquels je me suis engagé dès
le début pas d'interdiction sans
solution la vérité n'ya pas de bonne
solution
moi ce que ce à quoi je veux qu'on
arrive c'est que l'on ne dise pas et on
ne fasse pas croire aux riverains qui
sont de bonne foi
on cache le sujet qu'on ne traite pas
s'est donc dit non mais j'ai bien aimé
son sac on exerce très bon c'est pour ça
que je suis en train de vous dire c'est
bien la science et la science il faut
trouver la bonne méthode
comme c'est le cas chaque année
évidemment le président de la république
qui échange de très nombreuses reprises
donc avec les agriculteurs ils ont
plusieurs motifs d'inquiétude vous
l'avez entendu il ya donc les pesticides
le cliff aux athées a également donc la
politique agricole commune avec l'échec
des négociations il y aura à bruxelles
évidemment des macros va tenter de les
rassurer il ya aussi les viticulteurs
qui craignent les taxes imposées par
donald trump dans la guerre commerciale
qui oppose les états unis et l'union
européenne
et puis il ya d'autres personnes qui
manifestent leur mécontentement ils ne
sont pas agriculteurs on a par exemple
vu des gilets jaunes en tout cas on a vu
eric drouet qui a tenté et bien de
s'approcher du cordon présidentielle il
a été expulsé et bien du salon de
l'agriculture il a été interpellé par
les forces de l'ordre et une sorte de
mouvement de foule en fait lorsqu'il
s'est approché des manuels macron il
faut rappeler qu'il ya un arrêté
préfectoral qui interdit les
rassemblements de gilet jaune au salon
de l'aviculture et autour du parc des
expositions à porte de versailles des et
malgré cet arrêté préfectoral ils sont
un certain nombre à peut-être tenter des
actions il ya beaucoup de messages qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux de la
part de groupes de gilet jaune pour
tenter de mener des actions aujourd'hui
éric drouin a donc été expulsés de ce
salon il ya eu d'autres actions qui ont
été menées par d'autres organisations il
y avait une banderole qui a été affiché
dans ce salon de l'agriculture une
banderole où il était écrit stop c'est à
une banderole à l'initiative notamment
dan vais les amis de la terre extinction
rébellion ou encore l'organisation attac
propose d'écouter l'un des organisateurs
l'inde l'une des personnes qui a aidé a
déployé cette banderole on est là pour
sensibiliser réveiller un peu le ceta
qui est un peu pour l'instant un peu
dormant on va dire et qui pour autant
est en vigueur de façon provisoire
depuis depuis 2007
donc là on en profite de la venue de
macron pour pour dénoncer cet accord
libre échange en fait qu'ils aient déjà
qui est contre l'agriculture française
qui favorise donc tous les échanges en
parler encore encore un accord
transfrontalier donc avec les impacts
écologiques etc
derrière apparence avons aussi contre la
culture française qu'elle des des normes
sanitaires environnementales et sont
beaucoup beaucoup plus laxiste du coup
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
à noter qu'il ya quelques instants à
peine emmanuel macron a été interpellé
par une gilet jaune ils ont échangé sous
les yeux des caméras emmanuel macron a
promis à cette femme gilet jaune qu'il
était prêt à recevoir un groupe de
manifestants gilet jaune s'il arrivait à
se structurer ils ont eu un échange sur
un certain nombre de sujets maquereau a
par exemple rappelé qu'ils étaient
opposés au référendum d'initiative
populaire voilà donc pour les premiers
échanges des modèles macron ici donc qui
poursuit sa visite
on verra combien de temps le chef de
l'état va rester dans les allées du
salon de l'agriculture on se rappelle
que l'an dernier elle était restée 14
heures ce qui constitue un record pour
un président de la république
l'elysée à d'ores et déjà fait savoir
que cette année il devrait rester un peu
moins longtemps ici merci beaucoup
thomas bonnin pour toutes ces précisions
en direct du salon de l'agriculture